[Music]
you know that piece of furniture you've
been waiting for for months could be
even longer of a wait as the shipping
challenges we face for the past year and
a half aren't getting any better we
caught up with brian wachter of the
retail association of nevada he said
they're cautiously optimistic heading
into the fall and holiday shopping
season consumers have more income now
due to some of the latest government
projects he says like the tax credit for
children and he says folks have been
spending but there was a slight hit to
consumer confidence in the month of
august
we're still dealing with complications
from the suez canal blockage
in china we've seen a lot of ports go
down due to the recent surge that
they're experiencing of the delta
variant of covid in fact the third
largest port in china is currently
offline at the moment we've got
container ships that are lined up that
can't get into ports
things are backed up at the ports and so
i think we it is safe to say we can
continue to see
some of those problems materialized into
the holiday season
he says retailers are encouraging
consumers to start shopping early this
year for the holiday season due to all
those shipping challenges